this is a moment for Cersei where she
has a chance to maybe to flee and get
away if she surrenders but that's I
think anyone who knows Cersei knows
she's not going to make that choice her
feeling is if I give up the throne I'm
dead and so my only chance now is to win
and that's what she says to Ned Stark in
season one when you play the game of
Thrones you win you die
Dany is this young queen coming to try
to usurp her and sir she's not going to give
up the throne that easily tyrians
perspective is you know while we have
these various wars for supremacy and
everything let's not forget about the
people who are going to suffer the most
from it he can envision what will happen
in King's Landing if these two armies
clash and dragons are involved and it's
an obvious catastrophe she feels like
the odds are actually pretty good for
her at this point and she's willing to
roll the dice she's really back where
she was at the very beginning
emotionally she's alone in the world and
she can't really trust anybody people
have underestimated
Danny's strength many times before and
and no one's really done very well under
estimating her strengths unlike then
she's extremely powerful and unlike then
she's filled with a rage that's aimed at
one person specifically I think what's
probably echoing in Danny's head in
those final moments would be Meis into
his final words shakarez has clearly
meant for Danny misa-nee knows that her
life is over and she's saying you know
light them up
hey everybody it's Charlie this is going to
be my Game of Thrones Season 8 episode 5 trailer
video obviously
they're calling it the last war we don't
know what the title of the episode is
going to be
they haven't been releasing those till
after the episodes air because they try
not to give away any big spoilers if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Game of Thrones
videos there's a new round of that HBO
now giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video also mention a
little something about the spin-off game
of Thrones shows at the end of this -
obviously spoiler warning for everything
through Game of Thrones episode 4 though so starting with the footage before the
big battle you see Tyrion trying to talk
some sense into nares who's just looking
out over Dragonstone still brimming with
hatred for Cersei the way Daenerys walks
out of episode 4 / Dan and Dave is that
she gets this message quote-unquote
received from Missandei she's dying
dracarys burned them all although
Drakkar is in high Valyrian means Dragon
Fire literally but the way they say it
is that Missandei was trying to tell
Daenerys to burn Cersei in all of her
allies so Daenerys is like message
received
I will burn them all so they want you to
think from Daenerys his actions in the
look on her face that she's thinking
burned them all Mad King style I think
it's a bit of a misdirect though because
just like in last week's episode Tyrion
and Varys are actually worried that
Daenerys will go for bad Queen just like
her father when really we should also be
thinking about Cersei going full Mad
Queen although you would call her Cersei
the cruel because her actions are a
little bit more like maegor the cruel he
was a Targaryen king who put down a
faith militant uprising during his time
by burning down the great Sept of his
time with all the faith inside of it
just like Cersei did during season six
and he built the dragon pit in its place
we'll probably go back to the dragon pit
at some point in the next couple of
episodes even though you see Cersei
looking out over the city here there are
a lot of questions about this shot -
because it looks very different from the
sod of her looking over the city during
season 6 I'll explain what's going on
here but the really interesting thing
about Tyrion and this trailer here is
they're using a lot of visual metaphors
to make you think that he is in danger
because as he's walking towards Daenerys
visually look at the metaphor that
they're going for here he's walking into
the mouth of the dragon on the wall here
as if Daenerys is destined to end him
sometime in the last couple of episodes
like he's walking into the mouth of a
dragon he
said that he's afraid of Daenerys in the
last week's episode there are only
couple things that earring could do in
the last couple of episodes that I think
that would make dinners actually want to
end him even though it seems like ever
since the end of season 7 he's been on
the outs with Daenerys in terms of her
small Council she hasn't suspected Varys
is plotting against her yet but she'll
probably find out about that pretty soon
too I know a lot of people are expecting
Tyrion to betrays and Eris in the last
couple of episodes as part of this big
battle of King's Landing I do expect me
to do something really crazy but I don't
know if he would betray her in the way
that a lot of people are expecting him
to betray her so it seems like they want
you to think the Tyrians days are
numbered but I think the events leading
up to that potentially will be a little
bit different than people expect the
interesting thing about the shot of
Cersei looking at over King's Landing is
that in this shot during season 8
episode vibe she's looking directly at
the gate where they're going to be doing
most of the fighting where they had the
parlay in last week's episode to think
about this is that a lot of people were
confused because of the sight line like
you don't see the mountains in the
background like you see Cersei in season
6 episode 10 looking out over the city
you see the great set while she's
waiting for it to be blown up by all the
wildfire then on the left side of the
frame you see Blackwater Bay so people
are like wait a minute is this supposed
to be the same shot what happened to the
sight line so I think in this shot she's
just looking at over a different side of
King's Landing because remember the red
keeps it's here at the back of King's
Landing so to speak so she could look
out either side of her windows and see
different sides of King's Landing
so when season six I think she's just
looking out over the left side of her
windows which would be the south side of
the city and she's looking at over the
north side of the city during season
eight and that's where the gate is
a lot of you've also probably noticed
that the new season 8 intro also sort of
changed the topography around King's
Landing so now it looks kind of like
it's landlocked whereas in earlier
seasons it looked like there was the bay
right on one side like it was literally
bordering the bay and then on the other
side was mountains and there was no
giant desert area or anything like that
around the gates I think this is them
just fudging their season 5 stuff like
in season 5 they got a really good
exterior shot and this is in Dubrovnik
then because of the way they wanted to
shoot these battle scenes during season
8 episode 5 coming up they're just
trying to say that it's a different part
of the city even though it does look
like there's kind of a desert around
King's Landing so there are some
inconsistencies season to season
but for those of you asking about the
seasons like is it changing seasons now
because they supposedly ended the night
king so does that mean that winter is
going away and is turning into spring I
think the idea is is that it's slowly
turning from winter to spring but it's
still technically winter
like they say a dream of spring in A
Song of Ice and Fire there is currently
a dream of spring right now but they're
not quite there you see Jon Snow roll up
at the gates of King's Landing with what
few northern army members they have left
you see a couple stark soldiers you see
a few Knights of the Vale in the
background of this shot you see you're
on ships waiting for Daenerys drogon in
any other remaining fleet she might have
because of Yara Greyjoy's Ironborn
remember Yara Greyjoy left a couple
episodes ago to reclaim the Iron Islands
in Daenerys name and if there's any
special skills that they've given the
Ironborn the last couple of seasons it's
the ability to cloak their ships and
just show up deus ex machinist style so
Daenerys
technically still has ships available to
fight Euron's Ironborn even if she's not
thinking about your age away at the
moment there was a weird line of
dialogue at the end of episode 4 where
Dan and Dave said Daenerys might not be
thinking about Euron's Ironborn fleet
but they're definitely thinking about
her like wait a minute didn't ears just
forget about the fact that they have all
those ships there's a lot of discussion
that will go on these last couple of
episodes about characters actions and
people acting like they normally
wouldn't act people seeming stupider
than they normally would I think a lot
of that's just a function of them trying
to cram so much story into such a few
number of episodes so you could just
make the joke that there's a lot of
deleted scenes between episodes building
that character motivation for those big
twists and turns there's a shot of
Daenerys sitting in a darkened throne
room in Dragonstone they'll probably try
to juxtapose her with Cersei sitting on
the Iron Throne like you have the Battle
of the mad Queens so to speak Tyrion
looking like he's shocked it's something
Daenerys just said also in the throne
room maybe this is her just talking more
about destroying Cersei even if it means
collateral damage for the innocent
citizens of King's Landing that would
definitely shock him he still seems like
he wants to believe in Daenerys but if
she were to say something crazy like
that that would probably send him off to
do something even crazier to try and
stop her from doing it we finally see
the golden company march out of the
gates of King's Landing in formation you
can see their sigil on all the shields
it's a Pike adorned with gilded skulls
the schools are actually symbolic of the
skulls belonging to former captains of
the golden company they act
they do gild the skulls of their former
captains and put them on real pikes but
because they're not doing elephants I'm
not expecting them to do every little
thing that the golden company does from
the books if we're talking about real
world history I think a lot of the
design of the golden company on the show
is inspired by Macedonian army designs
you also notice there's a hooded figure
in the background here in a black cloak
walking through them in the opposite
direction into King's Landing
that might be Jaime Lannister heading
back to Cersei either to end her or to
die with her depending on how you think
Cersei dies in the next two episodes if
he really is going to end Cersei he's
going to have to roll dice with Arya to see
who gets the pleasure
then there's gray worm in the unsold
information preparing to fight the
golden company you have all the
Lannister troops atop the walls of
King's Landing Manning all those
super-sized scorpions you even noticed
that Cersei is also added those special
lion designs on the front for Flair the
new scorpion bolts are way nastier than
last year the tips open up and they're
designed to spin well in flight so that
the boreholes tearing through anything
that they hit then there's that last
shot of your on hearing dragons roar and
looking up into the clouds in the sky I
think the idea being the drogon and
Daenerys are just hiding above cloud
cover to obscure their attack vector
just making it harder for Euron to aim
the Scorpions fast enough to hit her if
she really wants to be clever she would
also put the Sun at her back during her
to send so that you're on and his men
would literally have to stare into the
Sun to try and spot her just making it
way way harder to aim precisely so big
challenges in next week's episode take
King's Landing without ending all the
innocent people in the process
they built out this entire part of the
city as a practical set so at some point
during the battle they'll be fighting up
and down this giant city street inside
the gates of King's Landing the episode
isn't quite as long as episode 3 and the
battle did not take us long to film but
it is Miguel sapota Nick's episode so it
is supposed to be a big battle episode
but it might not be quite as long and
drawn-out as the battle during episode 3
even though their forces are divided
between Blackwater Bay in the gates of
the city so it will be a bigger battle
from a geographical perspective just
because the area around King's Landing
is so much bigger than the area around
Winterfell there's the idea about
something stopping Daenerys from going
full Mad Queen whether or not you
actually think that plays out depending
on what you think her character arc is
going to be in the next few episodes
while Circe's and B in the next couple
of episodes will she die during the
climax of episode 5 or will she die
during the finale episode 6 when will
Cersei lose her baby will your ah never
figure out the Cersei was lying to him
about Jamie's baby he didn't seem to
perk up when Tyrion knew about the baby
in last week's episode he's like wait a
minute
I just found out about the baby how
could Tyrion possibly know about the
baby
and will Cersei go full Mad Queen if she
loses the baby during the battle and
what about Arya and the Hound because
they were last seen on their way to
King's Landing they left before Jon Snow
did and they said it would take a
fortnight for him to make it down which
is about two weeks so they should have
arrived at King's Landing way before Jon
Snow did when will we finally see
clicking bowl play out will that be
during the big battle because that would
be a perfect time to put it in how will
they pay off Daenerys as vision of the
iron throne room in the house of the
undying we do know a lot of people
wondering now maybe this is Dragon Fire
and ash instead of snow because as of
right now there is no visible winter
snow or anything around them anywhere it
almost looks like it's summertime but
chronologically like I said it's
supposed to have been two weeks since
the end of episode four when we begin in
the battle in Episode five so there's
just a whole lot of stuff that they got
us so up in this pushing them into the
finale I am expecting some of this to
spill into episode six I think it's just
a question of what's going to happen to
potentially prevent Daenerys from coming
back from the brink of being full Mad
Queen and when are they going to pay off
some of these other big deaths because
obviously big battle episodes they're
probably going to be a whole bunch of
other main characters that die during
episode 5 but what'll happen is is I'll
do some more bonus videos later this
week I will talk about the prequel shows
George R Martin recently said that three
of them are moving forward they're
filming the long night prequel series
starting I think at the beginning of the
summer so we'll hear more about that
pretty soon but they haven't said what
the other two prequels that are moving
forward are so I'll talk about that in a
video later this week but leave all your
bonus video requests in the comments
below I will do a Q&A video tomorrow as
well but congratulations to NEMA Musa
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Game of Thrones video please email
me on the about page of my channel so I
can get your contact details click here
for my Game of Thrones season 8 episode 4 video
and click here for my Game of
Thrones episode 3 video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome, I'll see you guys tonight!